it's all to kind of like wake up and and
and tap into our hearts and start to
operate from that space so the the
message that I kept getting when I was
there was that this is not punishment
because the first five days that you
know I just wanted to play victim and
Colin to hold me like why me this is not
punishment this is a strong opportunity
all I see is opportunity and light and
you asked me a question I go on a
tangent and I can't remember your
question can you ask that one more time
yes
so it's interesting you know I've had a
lot of spiritual work done over the last
four years since I've lived in Maui had
completely transformed as a person and
and my my purpose I believe all along
has been tan I want to help suffering
the whole world is suffering in some way
there's so many people that are
depressed that are numb that are in a
state of unconsciousness and I want
everybody to be able to enjoy life
really so I kind of it's interesting you
know I'm a physical therapist I call
myself more of a healer than a PT at
this point and yoga instructor obviously
all that other stuff but my whole
purpose before this happened was like I
want to get you out of pain I want you
to be able to enjoy life yeah really
that's it it's like let's let's get each
other happier again and now it's kind of
like it just kept coming in when I was
there it's like your purpose is to wake
people up your purpose is to shake
people alive to realize that we all have
this same thing inside of us I'm no
different than anybody else and we all
get to choose life on a daily basis we
all get to choose happiness it's like
which wolf we feed right on our
shoulders so making decisions and
actions and behaviors that are backing
that up to create we create the life
that we live so so really it's it's
interesting that it shifted so much from
a place of like want me to put my hands
on a patient and try my best to get them
out of pain and to have them enjoy life
a little bit to like now it feels more
like widespread like I'm reaching a
bigger body of people which is beautiful
and I'm just looking for that pyramid
effect in the most beautiful way that's
a bad word but somebody has a different
word I'll use it but that branch effect
where we can all just be like spreading
our arms out touching as many people as
possible to create that like positive
shift and light and hearts
yeah totally
you know it's so interesting because the
story starts off like I just got lost in
the woods you know it's it's hard to
explain what happened I that that's a
very grounded way to put it getting like
disoriented in the forest but there was
something bigger at play you know but to
answer your question specifically I will
say ma claw forest anybody that's been
there searching you guys no I mean you
turn your head one way and it looks
exactly like the other way exactly like
the other way I'm like which way is
north which way is my car
so Michael all fours in particular
there's something very tricky there in
that particular forest Haleakala I have
my bearings other places in the isle and
I have my bearings but that particular
it's just like it all went out the
window and the only thing I could say is
that you know I started off that morning
and I said I had friends plans with my
friend they got cancelled I said I had
the whole day to myself what I want to
do I need to connect to nature I need to
ground and so and it just came in so
strong Mach eval forest Mach well force
is I guess weird haven't been there
forever so I just went up there you know
got out of my car I was like well I'll
go for like a three mile like hike I I
really love to stay away from EMF I love
to [ __ ] from cell phones I love to just
truly dig my feet in the dirt and
connect to nature and and feel that and
so that's my goal three miles whatever a
couple hours and I don't I don't really
know what happened all I can say is that
I got out of my car it's like you know
I have a strong sense of internal
guidance whatever you want to call that
a voice spirits who everybody has a
different name for it heart my heart was
telling me walk down this path go left
great go right it was so strong go left
go right go left right I'm like great
this is so strong that obviously when I
turn around and go back to my car it's
gonna be just as strong when I go back
but it wasn't and it was probably that
it was so I took a break i sat down I
laid down on a tree I was looking at the
sky and when I got up and I tried to go
back the way that I came which I had a
sense of direction at that point the
path was not leading me back to my car
and I tried all these different paths
and then I was like oh shoot these are
not bike paths did you're not walking
patsies you're Boer paths
so the Boer paths were just leading me
into Boers dens and like you know
off-roading essentially and so at that
point I had no choice because everything
looked the same I said well the only
thing I have is my gut I don't have a
compass and a cell phone so spirit or
whatever you want to pray to I said I
just I need your help right now I need
to get back to my car please help guide
me and I have it like I said I have a
strong sense of guidance so I started
following that sense of guidance and
that sense of guidance is what led me on
my journey that's what led me five miles
away and and I believe that there is a
bigger purpose to my story it's not just
a girl that got lost in the woods it's
this it's everything that's happening
right now and that's why I was so off
the beaten path is because this this is
the result that needed to happen from my
experience
yeah it was all meaningful I'm trying to
think of yeah I mean it was interesting
you know it was almost there I've been
working with a beautiful psychic named
Ruth and I've been working with a lot of
the the strongest teachers in the world
have come to me over the last six months
to help guide me in a variety of ways
and little did I know they were
preparing me for what I what I'm calling
spiritual boot camp which is what I went
through and and Ruth recently the
psychic I've been working with she knows
she's guiding me through this meditation
she was like you're ready for your
spiritual boot camp and I'm laughing
with with Benny my boyfriend I'm like
you know we're going through spiritual
boot camp and we do so much spiritual
work on a daily basis I didn't think I
would be going through the gauntlet by
any means I thought I was doing enough
work and every day there was like a
different lesson every step there was a
different lesson it was like the more I
think the biggest thing that happened is
like I had to really get out of my head
I'm a very logistical analytical person
multitasking organization all of that
fell by the wayside I had to just leave
all of that behind and it's like if I
miss steps I sprained my ankle if I
misstep I twisted my knee if I misstep I
cut myself
it was like one step closer to not being
alive and at some point it's like you
know something slapped me across the
face and said whoa wake up put your feet
on the ground pay attention to what's
happening underneath of your feet it's
slippery out here it's dangerous out
here you could hurt yourself you could
die you know take this seriously and and
I just yeah it really it was it was the
most present I've ever been in my entire
life in my body grounded in my body and
like every single step was like I choose
life survival I'm doing this for my mom
I'm doing this for Benny
etc
and and so that was I'd say that was
profound being fully present I think for
a lot of us with so many distractions in
life it's tough for us to be present and
it was an opportunity what's called an
opportunity it was forced it was a
beautiful forcing opportunity but I
would say that you know something that
really that happened that was completely
profound was the one night I'm sitting
there and I I had at some it was right
after I sprained my I took a fall from
20 feet jams my left knee up was
screaming in pain I'm looking at the sky
like you got to be kidding me
and hobbled myself over it was like the
next night there was a flash flood
pretty it was pretty much like a flash
flood I was worried at some point that I
was gonna get swept away down just down
into the sea and I knew I was far away
from the state but the water was that
strong and I was sitting in a foot of
water on hard rocks that I knew were
digging into my skin but I didn't have
another choice and curled up into a ball
and like the only thing that I couldn't
sleep I was shaking so hard from my
adrenals and cold that the only thing I
could do was meditate and it was the
only thing that brought me peace and it
was at that moment of complete and utter
breaking down of a human being that I
reached the state of unconditional love
and and spirits like you know like
you've been asking for this we're just
gonna like strip all of these layers
back you have nothing else left you're
so raw you're so vulnerable the only
thing that you have is your wide open
heart and I felt my wide open heart
penetrate every single cell of my being
in any kind of dark spots that were in
my body
energetically whatever however you want
to think about it we're just lit up and
I felt myself like started to glow as
I'm shaking at a foot of water sitting
on a rock in the middle of a flash-flood
that was as dark but bright moments
yeah that was a that was that was one
for the record books
[Music]
hi
screaming up you oh my god so I've known
Javier for a few years he's crazy I love
him he's my dive instructor he's my dive
master we've been working together for a
while it's it's just so funny that he's
the one that came out of the woods and
and I'm seeing these guys like come over
me in the helicopter and I can't tell
you my heart just fell through my feet I
mean I just collapsed
I had a plant in my mouth that I was
planning on eating for dinner and I'm
crying and I'm in the woods and I don't
know how they spotted me I mean that is
pure that is a miracle
it's a miracle because I'm on this tiny
and I knew in the grand scheme of things
I'm in this tiny little piece of rock on
the top of this waterfall how the heck
are they gonna find me and then for a
second I'm in the woods and then that
second they find me it was a miracle and
when I looked up and I saw the
helicopter right over me and he's
pointing right at me I just like fell to
the ground and just started bawling and
and obviously at that point I'm like so
attentive and like this is my survival
this is my Savior I'm going to live and
it was the communication non-verbally it
was very clear they were like we have to
circle back around we can't drop down
there was no space there for a
helicopter I mean and when I I just
earlier that day I mean I was having
visions the whole time I had this vision
of Javier rappelling up the waterfall
and speaking his little head out and
saying I got you girl and and I just I
was like no way there's just no way and
when I heard his is like a Tasmanian
Devil coming out of the bush
and when I and I heard that Tasmanian
devil voice I was like just no way like
what is I hear a voice and then I hear
this other thing and and I heard it was
a Kris berquist and then I heard this
other thing and I was like that sounds
like Xavier and he's like you know who's
crazy force this is like oh my gosh you
know I just collapsed and it was like
the best first hug ever because what a
man I mean you know really it's just
like he didn't give up on me and and
we're friends but we're not that close
and he didn't he wasn't gonna give up on
me he was like I was gonna be out there
every single day no matter what like I
knew I had to save you and Kris
Bergquist who doesn't know me you know
it's just these these people I'm just so
blown back there's not a word for my
gratitude there's not a word for seeing
this in humanity seeing this Drive and
this is not willing to give up attitude
of like we're going to save you your
another human being you're in my tribe
and like we're gonna get you out of here
it's absolutely incredible
[Music]
you know what's interesting is like I'm
not one for social media and like you
know I obviously wanted to get lost I'm
like I had no idea how bad I wanted to
get lost but I don't pay attention to
social media this is what I believe is
that they're just saying and I'm gonna
probably screw it up but you know
there's there's a wolf on each of our
shoulders there's a good wolf on a bad
wolf and negative positive however you
light dark however you want to think
about it in this world I don't believe
it has to be in balance exactly but but
I do believe that whatever wolf you feed
is going to gain power and so I'm not
feeding those wolves I think there's a
lot of confused delusional people in the
world that I'd love to help and that I'm
not going and I've had a few disrupted
people come up to me and say some
disruptive things and and I feel bad for
them I mean really underneath of it all
just like the Buddha it's like I see
their suffering and I see their
confusion and I'm not taking it to heart
and I'm not taking that energy energy in
is the biggest thing so that's that's my
recommendation is like you can sit here
and dig your nose into social media all
day and and look at all these who I
don't even want to know what's on the
Internet as far as like stories and
whatever and so I'm just choosing not to
go there it's like ignorant and
ignorance is bliss in this case because
um I want to focus all of my energy on
the positive and like feeding forward
spreading the spark like let's like come
together as a try of the community let's
let the whole world know about this
let's let's change the way that we
operate as human beings I'm just
ignoring it
and you know I do want to give thanks to
my boyfriend Benjamin I mean I I know
he's he's under fight he's still under
fire you know and and without his like
perseverance like he was not gonna give
up on me no matter what he knew I was
alive we were communicating in a
different kind of way and and through it
all like he took a polygraph he's like
no big deal like I'll take a polygraph
Sara I mean Sara barely knows me she
stuck her neck out for me over and opens
- continues - and so I have a lot of
things for these people that are kind of
taking the fall for me sticking my head
in the sand I understand that but what I
do recommend is that you know let's not
feed that let's just like rise above and
look down on it and then see the
suffering underneath of all of it
I can barely hear you add Battier's yes
now so I'm I'm extremely healthy my mom
you know I talked to my mom on the daily
and I was like manifesting this whole
thing I'm like I want to know what it's
like to not be dependent on food I could
survive 30 days without food you know
these are words that came out of my
mouth the month before this all happened
which is just crazy and I'm so careful
with my words from now on please
everybody be careful with your words but
no no so I'm trying to think that
morning I didn't have any caffeine I'm
very careful with caffeine because we
all carry typically a load of adrenal
shock and caffeine feeds that and and so
I didn't have any caffeine I got up and
I was I meditated I cleaned a little bit
I was going to get together with my
friend Jen I had a suit a superfood
smoothie which is like you know if you
want to know what's in it
ashwagandha which is good from the
nervous system etc protein powder
whatever and I had an Rx bar and then I
and I had some water and then I went
hiking so I really didn't have much in
my stomach and I didn't have any
caffeine and I didn't have any sugar I
try to avoid sugar I definitely didn't
have any drugs or alcohol or anything
like that you know like anybody that
knows me and knows my spiritual journey
in the last few years knows that I get
high off of life and I can have people
and heart and so I don't know everybody
can have their little theories there I
don't care yeah
[Music]
hi
I do it's not that I think that it's
that I was it's that I feel to have a
pretty good level of communication with
what I call spirits God source whatever
you want to call it I have a very strong
spiritual relationship you know some
people aren't comfortable talking about
that I am because it guides my life and
and I will say that the thing that cats
coming in over and over again anytime I
had that victim mentality is that it
this is not your punishment this is your
destiny this is your journey this is
part of your path so after hearing that
multiple times I started to accept that
it was coming in to a place of
acceptance okay all this stuff is being
shed this is my journey this is my
journey it's like you know it kept
coming in and you want to heal people
you want to help suffering this is your
journey you have to be on this side of
things to understand to move forward to
really help people and so at some point
probably about halfway into the days
that I was out there I came into a place
of complete acceptance of that where it
was like this is my journey I have to
choose life there's a reason why I have
to keep myself alive and and yeah and in
my mind I mean you know I understood all
that this is so small with in my mind
I'm coming out of the forest making
maybe my mom's on Maui because she might
be worried do you know what I need so so
like I'm I'm just like I'm not one for
the limelight I'm not like oh man to
disappear the whole islands freaking out
I'm like Amanda disappeared I bet you I
wonder if Benny's got to hire another
helicopter company tomorrow because they
didn't find me today
you know I mean it's so small scale so
when I came out of the woods and
Javier's like yeah there's all these
people worried about you you're on
Dateline I was like what really like
your family's here my family's here he's
like are you kidding me so I'm just just
baffled
yeah again tangent sorry but this is
this is so much bigger than me and
that's I think that's the most beautiful
thing is like I'm so high I'm so
grateful to be alive I wake up in the
morning I'm like oh my god I had a warm
bed that I got to sleep in and my body
got to rest him to heal my ankles are
getting stronger like grateful for every
breath grateful for everything and I
hope I never lose that and I think if I
start to I'll get a strong reminder yeah
but the bigger picture of this whole
scenario of really what went down is the
most beautiful thing is his hope and
community and Aloha and Ohana and
Brotherhood and tribe ship and and all
about I can't reiterate enough as that
if I start to see like a movement occur
in the world it's like whoa I am so
stoked that my story could have done
that you know excuse me we need just
just a second to prep her for her I have
a doctor's appointment coming
okay
[Music]
I didn't take a nap
I did lay on a tree and sit back and
close my eyes and meditate so I enjoy
meditation I've meditated as much as
possible it's a very peaceful state of
mind I recommend it highly and it allows
us all an opportunity to connect to
something deeper within ourselves
something you know that's away from the
distractions of life so I meditate as
much as possible and and it was just
kind of an opportunity to close my eyes
to connect to nature to feel wind water
air you know all those kind of things
yeah but it wasn't like it wasn't a
lethargic it's like this is my day off
I'm gonna lay on this log and close my
eyes
I'm sure you probably are aware
and so some understanding of what
John maybe you would answer as far as
the rescuers are going to help that
yeah you know it's very interesting I
know him secondarily Kanu
is she goes through the same yoga studio
after go yoga and it's her brother and
and on the way so I've been working with
this amazing Shama and her name is Mary
Ellen she came from Southern Maryland
and she has been a pinnacle part of my
healing and understanding of really what
is going on and what's happening right
now being able to protect me
energetically and she said to me last
night she goes I know this is not and
this is not an opportune time but no one
needs your help and I was like wow you
know I will give anything and and I felt
that this morning I'm in the car with
mom and we're on our way and I said I
need to say a prayer for Noah it's just
coming through me it's not something I'm
thinking it's something I'm feeling and
it's it's a different circumstance I'm
just gonna call it different from my
understanding Noah was in a place where
he did leave a note and he wasn't really
sure he's confused and he wasn't really
he's not really sure what he wants out
of life at this point and and I can't
you know the only thing I can do is pray
for him and I can't be boots on the
ground right now but the only thing I
could do is pray for him and try to
offer him some spiritual guidance so
that he can find a deeper sense of being
a deeper sense of wanting to be here and
wanted to return to his amazing family
who I know his family through you know
Mau he's small and I know they're
amazing people and I can't imagine what
his dad and his mom and his sister going
through right now with him you know
going through this he's going through
his own Souls journey to figure out if
he wants to be here
so my heart really reaches out to his
family and my heart reaches out to him
yo is a gnarly place everybody knows
that you know it's it's a lot scarier in
my opinion than where I was given the
history and you know I guess this is a
perfect opportunity if if it's okay to
say I would love to say a prayer for him
and I would love to send that out
through these microphones and I hope
that everybody else can like sit with me
in their hearts and say that prayer from
their hearts that we can all like get
him back home if he chooses to be home
it is his choice as a human being
whether he wants to be here or not but
my heart really reaches out to Noah and
and and I'm sorry for whoever's cun
comfortable with prayer but this is just
happening right now so I'm sending a
prayer out right now Great Spirit angels
teachers guides helpers of the light and
only of the light and I'm asking with
all of these hearts and all of these
beautiful people behind this prayer
today that we reach Noah that we are
able to touch his heart to help him in
this moment of confusion to find clarity
for his life his purpose his self
to find the love within himself to stay
alive to find the love within himself to
stay alive for his family for his
community for his tribe and all of these
beautiful people that only only only
want him in the world that this is a
pinnacle turning point in his life and
that this will serve as a strong
foundation from him to build upon from
him to make a difference in the world I
believe and I feel that Noah has
beautiful beautiful things to offer the
world and that this is his opportunity
to choose life
and I hope his heart is open I hope his
mind is clear and I hope he was
protected by mother Maui and those Maui
mountains
I send all of my love and all of my
supports to his family and his friends
and the search teams and I ask that this
be taken more seriously than my than my
search this is an opportunity for us to
really really show up we have been
training we've been training through my
experience and now let's show up for
Noah right I I do believe that he's
going to come out of this a stronger a
wiser version of himself and I can't
wait to meet him thank you
I'm just trying to think about how to
word this I knew that was the case it
was like a knowing that they were that
was over the first day after I went
missing I heard the helicopters and I
was like okay great thank you Benny
like thank you for taking the seriously
you know calling in rescue efforts all
that kind of stuff but it was it was
really crazy to me you know I spent my
entire time the first week let's say
just trying to become more visible to
helicopters those helicopters
I really appreciate the efforts of
everybody of everybody on all levels
that came out to rescue me especially
those that were enforced by the state
there was a difference in feeling
between the rescue efforts and there was
something that shifted within the first
few days after the rescue efforts of the
state stopped I felt more heart what I
ask is that this be taken more seriously
that missing people be taken more
seriously that on a state level we are
able to expand those policies so that we
know that our tribe is taken care of
I hope that answers your question I
don't have much more to say than that
when am I going back you know cell
phones are great people everybody knows
that I'm you know I've been strongly
against certain systems for a long time
and like that was ignorant so you know
what I would say is obviously I should
have had a cell phone with me there's
GPS locator on there there's a reason
why we carry them all the time you know
obviously it's like you could go for a
hike by yourself it's no big deal just
like take a cell phone take some water
you know I just thought I was going for
a short little jaunt of like a run and
then back to my car but what I would say
is be over-prepared you know be no
matter what it's like I it's so funny
I'm always an over-prepare and I always
have food and water and sunscreen and
had and I always do that it's just that
day for some reason I did not and and I
that's why I believe it was part of my
spiritual journey you know I believe
that it was like all these things needed
to get stripped away all these comforts
so that I can go on my own journey that
was just my experience but I think
everybody knows in Maui you know it's a
lot it's a friendly jungle there's not
much that'll get you but but still like
be prepared you know Suns gnarly winds
gnarly rain flash floods you know and I
think anybody that has done any hiking
Hawaii knows like take extra precaution
and just pay attention to where your
feet are and kind of drop into the
moment and be present
it can get scary quick so if they had
not found me so